Greetings. My name is Dr. Long Nguyen.
I'm a physician scientist at the Massachusetts General Hospital.
I have the distinct honor and pleasure of calling this session to order.
It's entitled "Multi-kingdom Microbial Determinants of Cancer."
We have a QR code displayed on screen right now.
I'm told ostensibly that's mostly for people who are remote,
because you can log in and offer your questions in a
Q&A portal.
But I've also found that in the past, people in the room can use it
as well, if you don't feel comfortable getting up to a mic.
Introverts, we're here, we're uncomfortable.
Unite.
So we'll just get started shortly.
So I mentioned the session title already.
It's "Multi-kingdom Microbial Determinants of Cancer," and in due time, the part
of my talk will be entitled "Gut Microeukaryotes, Endogenous
Viruses, and Cancer."
I have no relevant disclosures today.
So we'll start today by framing the topic in this rather
new discipline of the cancer microbiome, then we'll walk
through some work that's come out of my group in recent years.
Part one is about a controversial microeukaryote called Blastocystis.
Part two
is a bit about what we found in terms of transkingdom dysbiosis
in a precancerous liver condition called MASLD.
And then part three is a bit of a sneak peek regarding ongoing and unpublished
work. And then I will gladly share the stage
with my esteemed colleagues here. There's Dr.
Caleb Ro from Memorial Sloan Kettering, who will be telling us about how
population scale sequencing resolves the determinants and consequences of
persistent EBV infection.
And then we've got Dr. Iliyan Iliev from Weill Cornell Medicine, who will be
sharing with us a little bit more about the cancer mycobiome:
truth, myth, and current data.
So a bit more about the multi-kingdom microbial determinants of cancer.
The gut microbiome literature thus far has been largely dominated by bacteria.
That makes a ton of sense.
But that's not all that's there. The gut harbors a rather rich
ecosystem that includes fungi, protozoa, archaea, and
viruses, and you'll hear us talk a little bit about each of those
kingdoms in some detail. And collectively, they constitute a
substantial fraction of the gut microbiome's
biomass, and encoded genetic diversity, as well as the metabolites that
might be responsible for the downstream biology that we observe.
Non-bacterial organisms modulate host immunity, metabolism,
and cancer susceptibility, but remain systematically understudied.
An important point here is that the gut microbiome and its comparatively high
microbial biomass is not necessarily the same as the intra-tumoral microbiome,
which is comparatively lower biomass.
They represent distinct compartments with distinct biology, and so we'll always
try to clarify what particular compartment we're
discussing. And this field is nicely framed by a
couple of laudatory recent reviews.
One of which was co-authored by one of our esteemed colleagues and
speakers here, Dr. Iliev, as well as a review in JAMA that came
out sometime last year.
So we use this timeline from the aforementioned review
that came out last year
to
offer a little bit of context for how high-throughput sequencing and the
culture-independent microbiome have really exploded.
Going back to 1911, we're not going to start from the very beginning, but we
have the demonstration that chicken sarcoma is transmissible by a retrovirus.
Consequently, we have the onset of what is being colloquially called the
genomics era in the early 2010s, where both Fusobacterium and
ptx positive E. coli were subsequently linked to colorectal cancer
incidence and severity.
And then more recent findings include Strep anginosus being shown to promote
gastric cancer in experimental models.
All this to say that the explosion of high-throughput sequencing
have really allowed us to do a much better job of
discovering not only who's there, but what are they doing.
So the first part of my talk is called Blastocystis: Friend or Foe?
Here we can see that the Mayo Clinic describes Blastocystis as a
microscopic parasite that can live in your digestive tract.
Researchers don't fully understand the role that Blastocystis plays, if
any, in causing disease.
Most commonly, Blastocystis organisms simply live in a person's digestive tract
without causing harm. And so it's this sort of,
not only notoriety, but indecision about what it actually does.
Is it actually a parasite? Is it a commensal?
You kind of see it described as both.
That makes this particular organism very interesting scientifically.
So Blastocystis, formerly Blastocystis hominis, which
you might have heard it referred to
by its prior name. It's a bit of a misnomer because it turns
out this particular organism is commonly found in the human gut,
but also other animals. So not just H**o sapiens.
It's categorized into genetically distinct subtypes,
at least eight of which seem to have tropism for the human gut, although there's
probably more we just lack from high-quality draft genomes.
Like I mentioned, it has a controversial clinical and ecological role, and
it's notoriously recalcitrant to growth in anything but the
simplest experimental communities.
But it can be detected pretty reliably with PCR and metagenomics.
So to boil down our work, we
performed a population-scale interrogation of gut microbiome among participants in
the ZOE PREDICT studies. A little bit more on that in a moment.
This was complemented by newly sequenced data from various privileged datasets that
we had access to, as well as publicly available data, all told
collectively comprising more than 50,000 individuals.
Consequently, to perform this study, we had to generate a customized computational
workflow to describe the landscape across 214 different hosts,
lifespan, and eras, where we described Blastocystis prevalence,
abundance, and subtype distribution, and subsequently found
pretty compelling links to diet, cardiometabolic biomarkers, body adiposity,
and diseases.So, as promised, a little bit
more about the ZOE PREDICT studies.
They comprise at least five different cohorts,
collectively one of the largest multi-omic population health initiatives linking
nutrition, individualized metabolic responses to food, and the gut
microbiome. At last check,
this
program has now enrolled nearly 400,000 individuals across three
different countries.
So for this particular study that I'm going to be describing, we jointly considered
and harmonized five different PREDICT studies.
There's PREDICT 1,
where we admitted over 1,000 individuals to
metabolic research kitchens and did all the omics.
PREDICT 2, where we ran back the same playbook in largely remote fashion.
And then various forms of the PREDICT 3 study,
which are largely paying customers of a precision nutrition app.
So here in this map,
we demonstrate that blastocystis is widely prevalent globally.
If you know anything about blastocystis epidemiology, this isn't going to blow your
hair back, but reassuringly, our large assembled cohort largely mirrors that
of single center studies, disease surveillance
databases, and various other
resources.
So one thing to point out is that we've grayed out any country that didn't
have at least 10 publicly available metagenomic samples.
So it's pretty striking that much of the world is pretty underrepresented in terms
of gut microbiome studies. And then you'll see that parts of Africa,
Tanzania, South Africa, Fiji,
they've got blastocystis prevalence rates greater than
40%, some even approaching 100%. And it just blows my mind that something
this ubiquitous can still be rather controversial in terms of its role in human
health and disease. At the very least,
it may indicate that it has a non-pathogenic role given how prevalent it is,
but at the very least, you can say we've got a lot of work to do.
So depicted here, in this box and whisker plot,
we've got blastocystis prevalence by age group.
And you can see that blastocystis is prevalent among adults,
maybe less so among children. And then not shown here is that it's nearly absent
among infants and newborns. This really suggests to us that vertical
transmission is not a mode of transmission for
blastocystis. And then very interestingly, among the 12 publicly available
data sets that we had that
enrolled non-human primates, we saw a non-trivial
prevalence of blastocystis, and almost all of these
animals
were held in captivity. And so this really suggested strongly to
us that
we may have stumbled upon a previously
undescribed zoonotic transmission.
So just some evidence that can be observed with
digital sleuthing in population-scale microbiome studies.
So depicted here in this line graph, we show that blastocystis carriage is linked
to the consumption of healthy diets.
Here,
we can see that with greater adherence to a so-called plant-based diet,
blastocystis prevalence increases monotonically.
And then here is a slice of a much larger heat map, where we were able
to demonstrate that here on the left, these are so-called putative good
foods based on their loadings with that aforementioned plant-based diet, as well as
their minimal level of processing, that with greater adherence to a
healthier diet, blastocystis prevalence was greater.
And then comparatively speaking, with a lower quality diet,
blastocystis tended to be less prevalent.
Here is where we performed a machine
learner to demonstrate that blastocystis can be accurately predicted by
bacterial gut composition, a previously undescribed trans-kingdom phenomenon,
where we perform not only five-fold cross-validation but more robust
sensitivity analysis using leave one data set out
machine learning, where we can see that the median
AUC is in the high 80s, demonstrating that gut
bacterial composition can accurately predict the presence of
blastocystis.
And excitingly, we were able to demonstrate that among the features that
were most important to this relationship
was canonical diet-associated microbes like B.
ovatus, and then
negatively associated with blastocystis prevalence is oral
pathobionts.
And then here, limiting our data set to those from the ZOE PREDICT studies,
we can see that blastocystis-positive participants generally had favorable
cardiometabolic profiles, including improved fasting and
postprandial triglycerides,
higher so-called good cholesterol in HDL.
They generally had improved responses to standardized test
meals, as well as lower circulating levels of this inflammatory marker called
GlicA.
And then, similarly depicted in this line plot here is that
blastocystis prevalence had
decreased with greater adiposity, particularly among people
who were overweight or obese.
And here, among the publicly available data sets where we could calculate BMI,
we found that for every one point increase in BMI, your odds of carrying
blastocystis went down by 6%.
Next, using a case control framework, which was defined at the study level,
where controls were essentially the controls in a
given individual study, and cases were
diseases that are canonically known for maladapted host
microbial interactions. We found a 29% decrease in the odds of harboring
blastocystis among disease samples.
In particular, this green dot here with colorectal cancer,
as well as a pre-colorectal cancer
condition called inflammatory bowel disease.
We're currently following up on these
leads.And next, in a randomized
controlled trial of 1,100 individuals, we performed a personalized
dietary intervention where blastocystis prevalence could
expand modestly, particularly among people who were adhering
to a higher quality diet,
and especially people who met pre-specified weight loss goals.
And we think that this may have implications for primary and secondary
prevention of obesity-mediated cancers on the basis of
data that we are still working on.
So to wrap up this part of the talk, here in a global scale exploration,
we show that human gut blastocystis has pretty distinct ethno-geographical
patterning. It's positively associated with favorable short-term
cardiometabolic markers and negatively associated with longer-term
outcomes like body adiposity and especially colorectal cancer and other
obesity-mediated cancers. Our findings suggest a
potentially beneficial role for blastocystis, which may help explain personalized
host responses to diet. And we have a little bit more
mechanistic work that we're not quite prepared to show that hints at how this might
be occurring. So stay tuned.
The second part of my talk is on transkingdom dysbiosis in MASLD.
MASLD stands for metabolic dysfunction-associated steatotic liver disease.
It's a mouthful, so henceforth it'll be MASLD.
It's a spectrum of disease where excess fat builds up in the liver.
It's asymptomatic, but it is precancerous, as I mentioned.
It's the most common liver disease in the Western
Hemisphere and is slated to become the leading cause of liver cancer worldwide.
As you might expect, it's associated with a variety of cardiometabolic
disorders, including overweight or obesity, diabetes, and factors such as
diet and smoking. Paradoxically, it can manifest in lean individuals.
Most studies on the MASLD microbiome focus primarily on the bacterial fraction
of the gut microbiome. So we elected not to focus on that.
We jointly interrogated transkingdom components,
taking a look at metagenomics, metatranscriptomics, as well as metabolomics.
And forgive me for breezing through this slide.
I just want to be considerate of our upcoming speakers.
So
this work was really led by the first postdoc in my group, Hansol Kim.
Our study population was the Nurses' Health Study II
where 110,000-plus female nurses enrolled in
early adulthood beginning in 1989 fastidiously provided
health-related and lifestyle factors every two years, as well as diet every four
years. And so Hansol's project, which was funded by the Massachusetts Life
Sciences Center,
we did a nested case control study of 211 cases of MASLD and their
502 controls, the majority of whom were unmatched
controls.
So this is a cladogram,
the bacterial tree of life.
I know it doesn't lend itself well to an audience presentation,
but what you're supposed to see here is that metadata of interest
go around the cladogram or the tree, and we have
diabetes, BMI, and MASLD with each tick
representing whether or not it was significantly associated
with that particular taxa or feature.
And what you're supposed to take away from this overview-type figure is that
sure, the tick marks can overlap between diabetes,
body adiposity, and MASLD, but for the most part,
the microbial signature of MASLD is pretty distinct
from that of obesity, even though the diseases are quite inextricably linked.
And so we were able to demonstrate that oral-typical microbes drive differences in
MASLD gut microbiome ecology, 66 differentially abundant
bacteria,
including an enrichment of so-called oral-typical
bacteria that are usually found in the oral cavity in MASLD, in
particular strep species.
And here we can see that oral-typical microbes drive differences in MASLD gut
microbiome ecology. To orient you to this figure, we've got the
beta coefficients for lean MASLD versus control and then non-lean
MASLD versus control, and we can find that off-diagonal, which is where
the beta coefficients don't necessarily agree.
We find pretty interesting biology and an enrichment of
pro-inflammatory oral microbes, especially in non-lean
MASLD.
This was a pretty interesting result, where we were able to demonstrate that
acylcarnitine is the largest class of enriched compounds in MASLD.
As their chain length increased,
there was a stark association with the microbes that we
linked to MASLD. Again, it doesn't lend itself well
to this particular presentation, but depicted here in the rows,
we have the differentially abundant bacteria as well as the
acylcarnitines that were sorted by chain length, and you can see this really
striking block structure that coincides
with diet quality and their association.
And so we found a very interesting
diet-by-metabolite
relationship that's mediated by the microbiome.
What about viruses?
In terms of agnostic high-throughput viral profiling, most
taxonomic profilers, which tell you which bugs are there, they ignore viruses
completely. They require de novo assembly, or they rely on pretty
unstable reference taxonomies. That's because viruses lack
universal marker genes. They evolve and mutate rapidly.
They share homology with our genes, with bacterial genes.
So taxonomy is particularly brittle across databases and releases.
So we tagged in a very talented PhD student named Jordan Jensen,
who will be joining my group for a postdoctoral fellowship, presuming a successful
defense this week.
Her clever take on this is to
generate 100 base pair marker regions as opposed to marker genes
to specifically identify which viruses are present,
and all of this is without the upstream wet lab viral
purification protocols that might otherwise be
required. And so this method, which we call
Baklava, the preprint is out, the repo is public, and
we think it represents a better mousetrap in terms of telling you which
viruses are in your particular
sample.And here we can
see that endogenous viruses distinguish MASLD and its subtype.
The very interesting result here is that the majority of them are so-called
unclassified or uncultivated viruses.
That is, they don't have a name, but we can reliably detect them.
This is offering us a lot of future directions in terms of
uncovering this so-called viral dark matter.
The one significantly altered virus that does have known taxonomy is
Punavirus P1,
which has never been studied in the context of MASLD but has been associated with
other pro-inflammatory disorders.
When we do a bit of genome gazing in terms of
what viruses are differentially abundant by subtype, we did notice
that
the viruses in MASLD versus controls, and especially lean MASLD--
Excuse me, that should say non-lean MASLD, consisted of generally larger genomes,
greater GC content, and a greater number of open reading frames, really suggesting
that in non-lean MASLD, you have these viral taxa that could be more
complex.
And then this was a very interesting result for us where we used a computational
workflow to predict
phage-host pairs. And what we were able to demonstrate is that
the viruses that were differentially abundant
in MASLD
were predicted to infect and kill their
bacterial host,
especially those that were differentially abundant.
So this to us really indicated bona fide predator-prey
dynamics,
where the enrichment or depletion of viruses that kill
bacteria could be responsible for some of the alterations in gut bacteria that we
see in this disease.
So we'll be a bit brief here as our time's running short.
But in summary, we performed high-resolution profiling in more than 700
individuals.
We show this oral typical microbe axis, and
what's most exciting is we provided this as a comprehensive resource without
controlled access. So if you
make your way to our data availability page, all of this data is free for you to
use
without signing up for anything.
Where to read more. We have more on host genetics, trans-kingdom interactions,
subtype persistence, and we even
profiled ancient paleofeces to show that blastocystis
is not just a sign of a modern gut microbial configuration.
So this was published last year, as was Hansel's paper.
In terms of ongoing work, now that we've built a better mousetrap, we think, in
terms of
generating viral profiles from gut metagenomes.
We went back to a cohort that we'd previously published on
in Lynch Syndrome, showing a distinct microbiome signature in Lynch--
viral signature in Lynch syndrome compared to precancerous polyps
compared to colorectal cancer.
This paper is currently in submission,
but we have found the work to be promising enough to want to
extend on its findings with a large consortium with many
collaborators who I'm sure you're familiar with.
Next,
one troubling
issue with current-day metabolomics studies is that
less than 1% of what we find has a mass spec
standard, meaning we actually know what it is.
And so we've got a computational workflow to sort of de-orphan these bioactive
metabolites, finding
differential associations between MASLD and controls, and especially in HCC,
suggesting that these metabolites may be
microbially modified. And so we have
experimental colleagues who are following up on some orthogonal leads that we've
generated. And of course, this will be the topic of Dr.
Kim's KO1 since she opened up her own lab at MD
Anderson.
And then finally,
we are generating a network-based framework to detect enzymes
that catalyze reactions of interest and microbial derivatives of
well-characterized metabolites.
So with that, those are my acknowledgments.
And if it's okay with the group, we'll just proceed to the next speaker, and then
we'll take Q&A all at once.
So it's my pleasure to introduce Dr. Caleb La Roe.
You for being here. I'll be talking today mostly about the virome and
specifically talking on Epstein-Barr virus.
So before getting into the scientific bit of the talk, I just want to briefly
introduce the group and the folks that actually did the work.
So I started my group in September of 2023 at Sloan Kettering,
and I like to think that we are a technology development lab that has increasingly
found really cool associations with viruses.
And so this has been something that has really been the focal point of the biology
in our group. And so today I'll be telling you really about a single story that was
led by Sherry and Aaron that are trainees in the group in a close collaboration
with Ryan, who is another fellow junior PI at Baylor
College of Medicine.So like many of you,
in 2020, the world changed the way that I think about science
dramatically, in that we had a new infectious agent that was
causing a global havoc, and it really sort of gave me pause to evaluate what
it meant to sort of coexist as a human with these infectious agents in
our society. And as I started to dig into this concept,
something that really blew me away was just how abundant viral particles are
on the human body, irrespective of an actual infectious state.
So there's this concept now of the human virome, which is the
constellation of about 380 trillion viral particles
that are coexisting on your body right now.
And so what that means is for every estimated human cell on your body, there are
about 10 viral particles. So many of these are phages, but many of these are also
eukaryotic viruses that are essentially constantly shaping the way
that our cells and our immune system is responding to any sort of
perturbation that we have in our body.
And so it's really this concept of a virome that is sort of fundamentally
changing the way that I think about the science that I do.
What I'm specifically interested in is
sort of contrary to the way that we've conventionally gone about virology, where we
see acute symptoms, we see someone with a fever or a rash.
The fact that some of these viral infections can actually cause chronic long-term
complications, but ultimately, since they don't manifest in,
say, the same acute pathology, these have gone understudied to date.
And so what I want to leave you with in this talk or what I hope you'll take away
from this, is that just due to the sheer abundance of viral
particles in and on our bodies, every time you do a DNA sequencing
experiment from human cells, you will be capturing viral nucleic
acids. And as a function of that, you can do some really insightful
biology just by kind of systematically reanalyzing your data
in a capacity that allows for new insights from these viral particles.
And that's exactly the approach that we took in this study, and I'll give you a
specific vignette on this.
So whenever I think about how chronic impacts of viral infections can be
very heterogeneous and how they're sort of non-intuitive in terms of
their long-term complications versus their acute pathologies, really, I think
Epstein-Barr virus is the poster child for this phenomenon.
So Epstein-Barr virus is a gamma herpes virus. It has a fairly large genome.
It's about 172 KB, and it establishes tropism in B
cells. But what's really fascinating about EBV is about
probably 95% of us, or probably all of us in this room, have actually been
infected by this virus. And so if you think about what
follows this acute infection,
there are a wide-ranging set of consequences that
ultimately follow. So it's now been definitively shown that multiple
sclerosis is a long-term manifestation of an Epstein-Barr virus
that can be acquired typically decades prior to disease onset.
In certain parts of the world, EBV is a common driver of nasopharyngeal
carcinoma, again, indicating that this virus does have oncogenic
potential in and of itself. But for most of us in this room, again, we've been
infected, but we had no sort of obvious acute symptoms.
You would develop mononucleosis, but typically this is controlled.
But fortunately, most of us do not have these long-term complications that can be
quite debilitating. And so the question that we've been obsessed with for quite
some time now is really trying to understand why is it that people are
responding so variable to the same infectious agent?
And ultimately, could we try to understand this variation in a way that we could
actually sort of predict and potentially intervene?
And our main hypothesis in this study and the way that we've kind of conducted
these large-scale analyses is ultimately anticipating that the genetic
variation in all of us as humans actually is underlying this
significant phenotypic response to this infectious agent.
And so we essentially try to build a platform to be able to understand how host
genetic variation could ultimately modulate the way that EBV infects and leads to
these variable long-term infection consequences.
So the key concept that we take advantage of in this approach is leveraging
the fact that as a herpes virus, EBV will leave a copy of its genome in
cells. So if you think about sort of a simplified model of viral infection,
cells in our body are going to be hit by this viral agent.
Some of them will actually become vectors for this virus to replicate
itself in. And fortunately, our immune system is going to kick in and clear these
infected cells relatively effectively.
But again, this key feature of herpes viruses in particular is that they'll
actually leave a copy of their genome in a subset of these cells, and this is a
phenomenon called latency. And so what herpes viruses do, will take advantage of
this latency to potentially then reactivate and have a secondary infection,
sometimes decades later. And so if you sort of
realize that there's a copy of these genetic materials sort of
stuck in some population of cells, what you can imagine doing is that if
we go and look at large-scale DNA sequencing data sets, including
biobanks from the UK Biobank or from the US-based All of Us, these are
very, very large data sets comprising nearly a million individuals,
where they basically just sample DNA from peripheral blood, including the B
cells that EBV is residing in. And so the vision that we've had is
basically we'll take those large-scale data sets that are comprising of
petabytes of data, ultimately look specifically at these unmapped
reads and ask, are these actually of viral origin?
And if so, then we can essentially unlock a new molecular phenotype to do a couple
of things. One, we could essentially ask this question of genetic variation
underlying how much EBV is stuck in our blood.
And we can also go and say, for those of us that have higher levels of persistent
EBV, is this indeed a risk factor of developing some of these chronic
conditions? And so the sort of pros of this framework is that it's very
accessible. All this data's been collected.
It's just amenable to some fairly straightforward computational
pipelines. The cons is that we're really restricted to DNA viruses and those that
are tropic in the blood. But fortunately, EBV checks both of those boxes,
so we're able to proceed in this case.So
explicitly whenever we go and look for Epstein-Barr virus by remapping
these unmapped reads, so again, what we're looking for is kind of evidence of EBV
sticking around in these B cells following their primary infection.
What we're doing again is reanalyzing this DNA and asking how much
of it is viral-derived.
What we do is sort of sum the coverage across all of these donors,
across these biobanks. So the x-axis here is the
depiction of the EBV genome and the reference genome.
The y-axis is the sum of coverage across everyone in the biobank.
And what you can see is that it's relatively flat for most of the genome,
which essentially indicates that we are sampling valid viral DNA.
But you can see these regions that I've highlighted in red and purple, and I
show you the actual sequences of those because these are repetitive, essentially
junk DNA sequences that are highly abundant.
And so what we have to do is essentially discard these specific regions to
get a sort of more valid quantification of this.
And I'll note that these biases were essentially reproducible on the left from the
UK Biobank, as well as the right from All of Us.
And so again, because this is a log scale on the y-axis, these sort of repetitive
DNA regions actually vastly outnumber the sort of bona fide viral
DNA. But sort of by combining all the different donors, we're able to identify
these low-complexity regions, mask them out, and then go and quantify
our cohort. And so to give you a depiction as to why this is important,
we're able to take advantage of the fact that in about 10,000 individuals in the UK
Biobank, they explicitly measured EBV serology.
And so this is a relatively small number compared to the nearly 900,000 across
these two biobanks where we had whole-genome sequencing, but it provides a strong
orthogonal basis of corroborating this as a technical platform.
So what we find if we then try to go put people into buckets from the UKB,
about 44% of people we don't see any evidence of EBV, either
from these low-complexity reads or otherwise.
But then another 40% we actually see only in that red or purple region that
I showed you in the past slide. And so essentially if you don't
handle these low-complexity regions with care, you would effectively
misclassify this 40% of individuals, which I'll show you in a second, it would
be sort of catastrophic for this. But what we wind up with is this sort of
far-right bucket of about 9 to 10% of people where these are
high levels of EBV-persistent individuals that we were able to
detect, again, just from these existing whole-genome sequencing libraries.
The same thing was in the case of All of Us.
In this case, we had an even more sort of biased low complexity
positivity, but again, something about 10 to 12% of individuals were
positive for EBV DNA.
So what I'm showing you now is this overlap with these 10,000 individuals with
serology. And so when I say unmask, that's considering all of these
regions irrespective if they're biased or not.
Considering those regions masked in the right, you can see now a very strong
overlap with the serology giving us concordance that this is indeed a valid
measure of past EBV infection. And this is a fairly
specific measure whenever you consider all the different serotypes that are
analyzed or available in the UK Biobank.
So this is probably the most important
sort of concept of what I'm going to try to convey to you.
So I'm basically claiming that in these population sequencing data sets,
there's about 10% of individuals that have these high levels of DNA
positivity. But you have to reconcile that with that about
90% of individuals are seropositive.
So how do you sort of square these two things together?
So what I'm showing you is essentially a simulation to kind of give you some
context for this. So this is purely synthetic data that I'm showing right
now. I'm simulating about 10% of individuals truly being EBV
negative, and then I'm simulating the remaining 90% as this normal
distribution in terms of the log number of EBV
levels that are sticking around in your cells following this infection.
Now you can imagine that due to the depth of whole-genome sequencing, we're only
able to essentially sample some tail of this.
Everything to the left of it is effectively zero, and that's what I'm depicting
here in this sensoring where everything to the left of the blue line essentially is
zero and we're not able to discriminate if this is low or this was actually true
negatives. So again, this is a synthetic experiment, but if you actually
look at our real data from the UK Biobank and then zoom in on these
two tails, they wind up matching up very nicely.
So what I want you to take away from this is that we're essentially identifying a
segment of the population that's in this right-hand tail, that they have very high
levels of persistent EBV following that primary infection so that
relative to the rest of us in the population that seemingly controlled the
infection more effectively, there is this
more abundant persistence of the virus in these individuals.
And so this 10% of people are special in the way that they processed or essentially
failed to process the virus. So we want to understand how are they different in a
couple of dimensions.
The other thing that I'll briefly say about this is that we do indeed believe that
this EBV DNA that we're detecting is a reflection of
this long-term latency. We established this by reanalyzing the GTEx
cohort, which did both RNA and whole-genome sequencing from peripheral blood.
And what we find here is that also a good chunk of individuals were DNA
positive, but very few if any were RNA positive,
which would point to either lytic or reactivation of EBV,
really indicating that this is silent EBV DNA sort of in steady state whenever
we're talking about this persisting in individuals.
So just to briefly recap this, this virus is infecting primary B cells, so
necessarily it's going to be picked up in blood whenever we do whole-genome
sequencing. Typically, we think about EBV infection from the concept of
serology, but here we're talking about it as a nucleic acid basis, which is
something that we can infer from existing whole-genome sequencing given that blood
is the primary substrate of these assays, and this is going to be a
transcriptionally silent version of the virus.
Just something that is sitting there, but seemingly not doing anything kind of in
steady state, but potentially doing something sort of over the course
of decades. And so now what I'll tell you about in the last few minutes is now that
we've identified this sort of novel population of about 10% of the
population, effectively are these individuals indeed genetically different in
some ways that effectively allowed for the virus to persist?
And indeed is the persistence of this virus predisposing
for risk that we can ascertain looking at the health records of these individuals
from these biobanks?So just to cut to the chase, indeed,
these 10% of individuals have a different genetic architecture than those
that are more effective at clearing the virus.
So we did a genome-wide association study of over 400,000 individuals of
non-Finnish European ancestry, and we detected 25 conditionally independent
loci. You can see many genes that are sort of reassuring that they probably
have something to do with either B cells or viruses.
We find many significant associations in antigen presentation and
processing regions. We also see these in transcriptional regulators of B
cells and other immune cells, as well as signaling molecules.
So you can sort of get the sense that genetic variation that sort of controls the
complexity of immune response similarly is controlling the way that our bodies are
responding to these infections. Now, those are anecdotes, but sort of systemically
you can ask: Does this overall genetic architecture look
like the predisposition of different diseases that we've observed
risks for? And indeed, what we see is this axis where
what predisposes you of having this increased levels of EBV is the same
genetic risk loci that are predisposing you to develop systemic lupus, type 1
diabetes, and rheumatoid arthritis.
So this is just in the context of European Americans or
individuals of European ancestry.
What I want to say is that if you look at other individuals with more diverse
ancestries, that is a feature of these genetic biobanks.
We can recover additional genome-wide hits at loci like TERT and
GAST1B,
as well as even more loci when you factor in individuals from
America, BCL11A, MIC, these other sorts of B cell factors.
So in total, we identified 45 different regions in the genome that ultimately are
underlying this EBV persistence risk.
Now, whenever we look at what are these individuals with this high levels of
persistent EBV more likely to develop as a function of what ICD-10 codes are
in their health records, we see a few dozen different
phenotypes that are genome-wide significant.
Several entities that make a lot of sense, things like individuals that are having
this persistent EBV also seemingly are more likely to have been infected with
HIV, which is consistent with an immunosuppressive state that ultimately
allows for EBV to also persist. We see a variety of autoimmune
diseases like rheumatoid arthritis, as well as respiratory diseases like
COPD, all of which that have been implicated by EBV infection in the past.
But ultimately, we do see quite a few different neoplasms in the context of both
lung cancer as well as lymphomas, again, all sort of consistent with things that
we've sort of known having studying EBV for the last couple of decades.
These effects are often quite concordant across these two different continents and
these two different biobanks.
And so what I want to point to, though, is that a lot of these kind of more common
phenotypes have already been flushed out in some capacity.
But what our data is allowing us to do is assay thousands of these health records,
and so ultimately, we're able to find a variety of rare neurological diseases,
among other, that are seemingly associated with this high persistence of EBV.
So again, we're essentially able to look at comprehensively, what is this virus
predisposing to risk? And we identify many that I'll
refer to the manuscript for details.
So ultimately, a feature of our data is not just the host genetic variation, but
we're also measuring the viral sequence.
So very conceptually similar to how we think about surveilling, say,
wastewater for SARS-CoV-2 variants.
We can also use our data to understand are there specific EBV strains that are
more or less likely.
And this is a particularly relevant question because we look at the incidence in
nasopharyngeal carcinoma, we see a strong geographical bias where
individuals in Southeast Asia seemingly are more frequently developing
cancer following their EBV infection, whereas those of us in the Western
Hemisphere seemingly are not.
And so what I want to convey is that our data does not really allow us to
reconstruct a full EBV genome per person, but we essentially get this
synthesis of, again, something similar to a wastewater
sequencing of just what is roughly in the
ambience of what you're detecting here across the entire continent.
And so what I'm showing you here is a scatter plot of these allele frequencies
of what's in America versus what's in the UK, and these are overall pretty highly
concordant, kind of consistent with there being quite a bit of geographical sharing
of probably these different strains across the Atlantic.
But ultimately, what we were able to do is identify 31 variants of
unknown significance that are in the EBV genome that have been reported
from sequencing EBV strains in parts of Southeast Asia.
And what we find is that for about 27 of these variants, they're actually highly
circulating in America and in the UK,
at least suggesting that these specific variants are probably not the ones that are
driving this nasopharyngeal phenotype, and instead, we can
refine it to these other four that we're experimentally following up on right now.
So again, sort of conceptually, this is a feature of the data where you're able to
not just understand the host genetic variation that underlies this EBV
persistence, but also what EBV strains are persisting
across these continents.
What's been really exciting to see is that even just since our paper came out and
sort of pointed to these concepts of sort of both host and
viral genetic ancestry, there was a paper last week
from researchers in China that specifically showed that some of the regional
variation in EBV could indeed be attributed to differences in
HLA genotype as well as strain-specific
nucleotides as a function of creating or destroying a immunodominant
epitope that CD8 T cells could recognize.
And I'll further point to other corroborating work from Kirsten
Lugwitz lab as well as Paul Roelofs lab that also spoke to sort of the
concordance of our understanding EBV really by using these whole
genome libraries.
So with that, I'm almost at time, and I'll give you a brief summary again of what I
told you about. So we're able to retrospectively study EBV just by looking
at whole genome libraries that are already collected and already available in
hundreds of thousands, if not a million people.Using this as a basis for
doing genome-wide association studies, we're able to uncover 45 distinct
loci that underlie this risk of persistent EBV infection
following primary infection. Ultimately, whenever we now
pair that with phenotypic records, we're able to uncover novel chronic
conditions that are seemingly linked to EBV, as well as replicating prior
autoimmune and respiratory conditions.
And then ultimately, a feature of the data is that we can further interrogate viral
genetic variation to assess some of these strain-specific phenotypes that we're
seeing in parts of the world. And what I told you about today really is a
conceptual platform where you can use these large-scale data to find these novel
associations. We focused on EBV, given quite a bit of prior
work, but this is one of probably 100 viral species that we've been able to
characterize that will inhabit and persist in the peripheral blood.
And further work for us to come is being able to identify these other 100
species to potentially identify whether these are going to be also driving
long-term chronic phenotypes.
With that, I'll close and again acknowledge the group as well as some of the
funding that's been ambitiously supporting a young investigator.
Would be very eager to collaborate if any of this work that I described is of
interest, specifically in some of these newer viruses that we're going after.
And with that, I'll turn it over to the last speaker for the session and take
questions after. Thank you.
And last but not least, we have Dr. Ilian Iliev.
Hello, everyone. It's great to be here.
I realize I
put this ambitious title, so let's see how it goes.
All right. There were already a few
presentations on the microbiome and many studies that
have shown how important actually the microbial
communities are in cancer, both for the development of
the cancer, but also for the positive effects that we are seeing
after immunotherapy. So when we think of
the gut microbiome in that situation,
we can think of this conglomerate of bacteria,
viruses, but also fungi.
And this is the part that we call the microbiome.
So those communities we started investigating now
probably
13, 14 years ago, and we developed different
approaches to visualize them, to study their immune properties,
and to characterize
their composition and genetically characterize the different
strains that are living into this community, which led to the idea of the
gut microbiome.
So fungi have been known for infections, and in the cancer field, what
they were known for for a long time is that they infect patients
that have suppressed immune system.
Bone marrow transplant patients are on heavy antifungal
medication for a very long time. But what really became
exciting here is that over the years, we
saw that specifically in patients with inflammatory bowel disease,
that some genetic mutations that lead to specific
phenotypes that we investigated in mouse models can
basically lead to this
aggravated response where the fungi can lead to more
inflammation. And that became something more
exciting to investigate because now we are looking at something that is
actually driving the immune response.
So
this is how it looks. So you have then the fungal colonization, and it kind
of puts up the volume bottom of the
inflammation.
But how about neoplastic processes, and especially neoplastic processes in
the gastrointestinal tract where those communities live?
So before going into that, I want to give a shout-out to a few studies
over the past few years that have been really
focusing on those fungal communities.
And
there have been some progress, but there have been some debates as well.
So we went to investigate that on our own, and
I will start here with a few slides on the work of Anders Dahlman.
When we started looking into that, we basically
went into the TCGA, where you have all this
information about the patient's epigenome, genome, transcriptome, proteome
data, but no microbiome data. So what Anders started doing
in the beginning, he applied--
I'm simplifying things here because I have 20 minutes, but happy to talk, and
Anders is here, so if you're interested, you can talk to him.
But basically, he developed this pipeline, which is based on
PathSeq, and then he went to look at different
wells that are contaminated in those
sequencing runs here and started looking in
tumor-associated fungi. So what was very shocking
in his first studies here was that, okay, we found
some commensal fungi that we also see in
the gastrointestinal tract of fibroid patients, but we found also
fungi in about
30-plus cancer types that have nothing to do with the surface of the body.
And he found even this portobello mushroom that you
can buy from the supermarket. It was basically in the
brain of those patients. So obviously, this is science
fiction here. And we started actually discussing.
It took us probably one and a half year to come up with a concept how to
really go about that. But I will summarize it in three
postulates. So if you find actually a fungal
species and its DNA, you should be able to basically
assemble in some way its genome. So that's what Anders
started doing in the beginning, so he could actually look at those
metagenome assemblies, MAGs, how people call them,
and candida albicans, which is one of those keystone species.
He found it in head and neck cancer, in esophageal cancer,
in stomach cancer, but he didn't find it in the brain.
So that was very encouraging.But of course, if something is contaminant,
you will see exactly the same thing.
And that would happen with another fungal species, Malassezia restricta.
Its genome was present in all different cancers, but it was present also in
the brain. So that's a clear contaminant.
And the third postulate that really changed the game is that if you have
those false positive alignments that are
pieces of DNA that are repeated across species,
you should see this similar pattern of sequences across different
tissue types, and that where the portobello mushrooms and many
other fungi actually came up. So when Anders integrated
all this into the pipeline,
what we called vertical and horizontal QC,
that led us to the tumor-associated fungi, but he didn't stop
here. So he will have a paper coming up in Cell on the multi-kingdom
microbiome in a few weeks, so watch out for that.
But from this study, actually, something very important came up.
So if you look at head neck cancer and esophageal cancer,
there were only very few fungal species that we could detect,
and the same repeated in stomach cancer and colorectal cancer.
We found only a couple of species in lung tumors, but not in any
other types of cancer. So that was very important.
That inspired actual validation studies here.
And if you look at the colorectal cancer, COAD here,
you see that there is a lot of Saccharomyces cerevisiae.
So this is basically a yeast that comes with the food.
So we started thinking here we should do some validation,
and the kenda alignments were not that abundant there.
So we went to a second cohort where we collected our
samples and went in a very simple way.
We started basically looking there if we can isolate those
species from the samples, and we could isolate, actually.
So these dots here show
three different patients, and we could isolate candida albicans, candida
lustini, candida tropicalis, and in my lab, we can
identify them and all that is not a problem.
So that's very cool. But what about Saccharomyces cerevisiae that we could
not isolate and which is very prevalent?
So what Anders did here, he went with the
RNA-seq approach. Basically, there is
RNA-seq data into TCGA.
So we looked basically what fungi are present both
as RNA and DNA to think if there could be
some transcription. And those commensal pathobionts here,
candida albicans, candida tropicalis, candida glabrata, all of them, we
could detect also the RNA, but not for Saccharomyces
cerevisiae or for cibaria and lagarina, which
are coming from the food. So that really
focused our thinking here, and I put that as this
triangle that I will go very quickly through each side because that's how we
think about the microbiome nowadays in the tumors.
So on the tumor side, so is that only association
or is there any causality?
So Xiangyu Pan in the lab went to look actually at
ITS sequencing data, and again, candida albicans really
picked up in the colorectal cancer.
So we started thinking, okay, this is probably a species that we'll focus on.
But we had also those other isolates that came from those
tumor samples. So Kyosuke Akabe in the lab started
doing this AOM/DSS model where he could colonize actually the
mice and induce
DSS colitis, induce EOM to induce basically
the tumor genesis. And what turned out is
that of course you have some tumor genesis
when you do that, but with candida albicans, this is aggravated, not
with another species, candida glabrata.
So now we have this very productive collaboration with Lars Vereske where
we are looking actually at other models and how that really
works. So from this and other experiments that I
will not have time to show you here, we think there is some causality
here. So were fungi actually present at the
tumor? So that's a very hot topic. They're
intra-tumor bacteria. So how about the fungi?
So we wrote this review actually with Anders and with Laurent
Zitvogel, and it was more like a thought
process here. So we had it as an opinion, but they said, "Oh, it's
pretty big, so it should be a review." But basically, the idea here is you have
those cancer-associated microbiomes,
which basically can act at a distance.
All the work of Laurent Zitvogel and others that have shown if you
have actually immunotherapy responses,
that could be controlled by the intestinal microbiota.
So those are cancer-associated species, but they're not
tumor-associated. If you look at the tumor, what you have there
is basically intra-tumoral, and we had a very nice presentation
from Susan Bowman yesterday. Or you have those
mucosal-associated species such as E.
coli or the work of Lars. He also presented
yesterday. And there are those ambiguous species that come in one study.
It's a very big study, but then you don't see another study about it, and
you
cannot put them anywhere until there are more studies.
So we went for candida albicans, and what we found about it, it's
actually associated with the mucus here.
So it's in red, candida albicans is in red.
This is the colon tissue here, the tumor tissue, and then the
nuclei of the tissue, and then you have the mucus.
So it actually lives in the mucus. So it's a
mucosal-associated fungus. So what it does there,
we started looking into that, and we had another study where we
borrowed some ideas from. So we have this very large collection
of human
primary strains that we isolated from many patients.So
if you look at those candida albicans strains, all of them actually look
differently. So all this is candida albicans, but it's different strains.
And if you prompt them to produce hyphae, which is this virulent form of the
fungus, you can see that yeah, some of them
produce hyphae, some of them produce some hyphae, some of them don't
produce any. So that's like a evidence for this
phenotypical difference that is happening.
They are as different as the people they come from.
This is AI generated, so it's not the real patients.
No HIPAA problems here. So if you then
start thinking about it, we went into the big population
and developed those phenotypical assays.
And with those assays, what we realized is that some strains can
be damaging to the cells and some of them are low damaging to
the cells. So we characterized them this way and started looking what they're
producing, basically. And, what came out as one
of the factors was this toxin called candidalysin,
which is a peptide that candida produces, and it's processed, and it
is actually genotoxic. So when we look at those
candida-positive tumors in both stomach cancer and now we
are looking also in CRC. So if they are candida
positive, there is this IL-17 and IL-1
response, and you know IL-17 has this dual
role in cancer,
depending on where it hits. It can actually lead to proliferation
of the stem cells, or it can lead to some prevention.
There is a recent study that came in Immunity.
So we looked at this cytokine because it's actually
induced. Those Th17 cells are induced by candidalysin, and we
published a paper on the topic. And what turned
out is if you actually target candidalysin, you don't
induce this damage to the epithelial cells, and then you have the
decrease of IL-17 cells. So it's one area
where basically this fungal factor can guide the
response, and we are looking more into that side in the tumors now.
So the bacterial side is another part of the
triangle. Again, I put this triangle because I realize it's a very
ambitious title, so I should do small piece of all of it.
So the bacterial side,
again, if you were at the session yesterday,
there were representative studies there that show very
nicely that if you have this gut microbial dysbiosis,
you have actually the growth of E. coli, and then you have
F. nucleatum. But what's very interesting about F.
nucleatum is that a lot of it looks actually being
transferred into oral cavity. And then when the patients develops
the tumors, it gets into the tumors.
So
why I'm talking about that? So basically fungi and bacteria, they share very
similar niches in the gastrointestinal tract where those
cancers are happening.
And we were part of this study, which is
basically FMT study in patients with ulcerative colitis,
and those patients are at very high risk of developing
colorectal cancer. So what we learned from this study, very
descriptive, but because there we had responders and non-responders, we could
actually stratify the patients. What we learned
is actually, if you deliver this
rich community of mostly bacteria from
those FMT donors into those IBD patients, what you do
is you can actually expel candida, and together with that,
you decrease basically the immune response that is happening to candida in those
patients. So it's observational, but it's
actually in a human cohort, which actually
inspired another study that we just started. I never presented that.
I have few slides. I think it's actually interesting to talk about it here.
So what we observed
in this unpublished study yet, we observed that actually, if you
compare oral samples and gut samples from the patients,
the strains of candida albicans that clonally expand, they actually
are shared between the mouth and the gut.
And this here is each strain, full genome sequencing.
Can we do those trees here to see how similar it is?
This is patient one, patient two, patient three.
You see all the strains actually are shared basically
between the gut and the oral
mucosa. So of course, this is again observational,
but it inspired a clinical study where we use this
phenomenon. And
in this study, we were thinking, "Okay, can we target actually the fungal
microbiota here?" So we started thinking, okay, it has to be a drug
that is easy to take, otherwise it's very hard for the patients to
comply.
The ability of the drug to reach the gut so it can target the
candida in the gut as well. And we had this criteria
that it should be affordable because all the drugs that are used
basically nowadays, in IBD and
for cancer cure, they are very unaffordable.
So many people actually cannot afford that around the world.
So we started looking at something that is a small molecule and that is actually
off patent, so we can use it in this trial.
And then it should have a good safety profile.
So what that drug was is a drug called
fluconazole. So you can buy it for,
in some countries you can buy it for a few dollars.
In the US, okay, you have to pay $200, but that's not that much.
And you can actually give this to the patients for a longer
time. And it's used actually as prophylaxis.
Of course,
because we selected the patient with this oral problem where
candida grows, all of them have to be treated.
So we compare this drug to another drug which is called nystatin, so the
patients can use it to wash their mouth with it.
And it's not placebo controlled study, but you compare the two drugs
here.And we also did this Mycelex torch, but
the patients didn't comply. They didn't like this drug.
It has to be in the mouth for one hour, and then you have to do that twice a day,
and it doesn't taste well, and it just didn't work.
So I will tell you only about those two drugs here, fluconazole,
which we call the give group here, and oral
nystatin.
So we followed the patients for eight weeks. We gave the drug for two weeks.
We were looking only at the induction here because it's the first study, so you
have to start from somewhere. So what happened actually, if
you give the oral drug, you clear the oral candida,
so the patients don't have thrush anymore.
But in the gut, you accomplish nothing.
So candida is very high there.
If you give the fluconazole, you clear the candida from the mouth, but you clear it
also from the gut.
Okay, so that's very good. We did actually also plating here, so that's
microbiological. So the same thing with oral,
you don't affect the gut candida. With
the systemic drug, you affect actually the gut candida
very strongly. Only one patient didn't respond. This is the median here.
Some strains can be
resistant.
So
what we are targeting here is cand albicans, and it's
targeted over the weeks if you give the fluconazole.
We don't target the fungi that are
resistant to
antifungal drugs such as candida parapsilosis, but those don't do
anything in our model, so that was a good control here.
So what I showed you from the FMT study, if you actually give
a huge amount of bacteria, you can
kick off actually the fungal colonization from the gut.
But
can we actually think of the opposite?
So now we are targeting the fungi, so what happens to the bacteria?
So what Shangyu did here, this
analysis of the patients from week zero
to week eight, and this is the delta of bacterial diversity.
So if you give basically nystatin, actually the bacterial
diversity doesn't recover, it even still goes down, and that's consistent with
the disease that is developing in the patients.
But if you give the fluconazole therapy, you start seeing actually
recovery of the ecosystem. And when we look more
specifically, bacteria such as Faecalibacterium
prausnitzii and
the-- What was this one?
Roseburia intestinalis, exactly.
Very good. Thank you. So those are actually very good
butyrate producers. And butyrate is very important
for the recovery of the intestinal epithelium.
So we started looking into that immediately when we saw this ecology.
And we did a lot of metabolomics, and we are now
actually in one big consortia here also that is
happening in San Diego. So we are looking in more metabolites here.
But if I show you only the butyrate, you can see that there is this
butyrate recovery and production if you actually kick off
candida. So that's something very promising, and we are looking how
this really works now.
And
different people in the lab are working on that.
So with that, actually, I think I went through the triangle, didn't
go very deep, but I hope I introduced different concepts here,
which I thought was the purpose of this presentation.
And with that, I would like to thank
the people involved in this work,
Kyosuke Ikkawa and Shangyu Pan, actually from the lab.
They have been working on that recently.
Anders Domán started it, so now he's in Dana-Farber,
and he's very successful, so very soon he will be looking for a
position. So
if somebody has an open position,
I think I can highly recommend.
So our collaborators from Weill Cornell, Helen Sherrill,
helping with recruiting 53 patients actually for this study, which is
admirable work for a clinician to be able to recruit.
Steve Lipkin,
and with Lars Vereske, we are actually having now
this very interesting project where we are looking at the mechanisms.
And thank you for having me here.
Okay. And with that, we are open for questions.
Hi, thanks for a really fantastic session.
All of your talks were great. This is for Dr. Leroux.
I
study Hodgkin lymphoma, and I've come to also the
conclusion that it's how the host handles it.
And so a few points. First, the timing of
infection determines the response to some
extent. As you said, everybody gets it.
We have noticed that in young adults in this country,
the percentage of EBV positive tumors is very low, although
most people are serologically positive.
However, in the UK, it's higher.
Mm-hmm.
And so we're having this ongoing discussion with the
Europeans because they think it's a huge cause, and it's not here.
So that's one interesting thing. The second interesting thing is that I have a
twin study, and I have a lot of twins.
We published a paper on just self-reported mono.
Mm-hmm.
MZ twins were twice as
concordant as DZ twins, but there were still a lot, a very
large number of discordant twins.
So considering mostly that they have the same genome-
Yeah
... and the HLA is the same. So that's something that I would love to talk to you
about and
look into more.host responses. And the final thing is,
for this Hodgkin's, we did a GWAS, but I don't think we analyzed it
correctly. So I just want to talk to you about that too, because we looked at
exactly the same question as a GWAS of viral load,
basically. And we had one hit,
which I didn't see on yours, but I would love to discuss the
analysis and, in fact, all of this with you, including the
twins, which I think are interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah. And I also do multiple myeloma and obesity, and your talk on
Dr. Meehan was also great. So, thanks.
Well, yeah. No, thanks for all the exciting points.
I guess I'll just point again to this study that came out just six days ago in
nasopharyngeal carcinoma. So it really was as simple as
a specific HLA class and a specific strain of EBV that would
permit or exclude an immunodominant epitope for training those CD8
T-cells. And so whenever you're evoking the differences in
incidence of these EBV-positive lymphomas across the UK and the US,
my first inclination is just the
differences in HLA alleles across these two continents could very easily
drive that. And those were by far our strongest risk alleles,
where you would see effects size about 100-fold if you had a certain
HLA allele for being able to present and probably deplete EBV
from the population. So,
I think that there's, again, just based on this
nasopharyngeal study, just that HLA hit effect could be sufficient.
So I think that would be my first opinion.
On the other hand, you found All of Us, UK Biobank, obviously
US, UK, right?
Yeah.
And there was about the same percentage that had the-
In the context of the
virus sticking around in blood. But I think certainly in a tumor ecosystem, like
the settings that you're describing, that's a slightly more sophisticated phenotype
than what we're seeing. So I think-- And it could also certainly be an
environmental exacerbation by the different continents, certainly.
But
I guess from spending my last couple of years thinking about this problem, it's
just so clear that the HLA variation in people for how
EBV is getting processed and presented is just the dominant signal in terms of--
And so it's super interesting then to hear about your twin study, because
ostensibly that's controlled for, and you would still have some other variants
there that would maybe be explored.
I'd love to talk to you further about it, to contact you and-
Yeah, that'd be great
... collaborate. Thank you.
Thank you.
Awesome presentations from all of you guys.
I guess I'll start the question for Long.
So I thought the analysis you did of
predator-prey dynamics between viruses and bacteria is really fascinating,
and it's a question I've been interested in as well.
And I'm curious your thoughts about the best way
to
analyze and interpret those kind of patterns, because a lot of them are going to
be correlational, right? So you may have some cases where a
virus is persisting in a living bacterial cell.
It's not killed.
Where you may see a very strong positive correlation than you might see in
cases where the
virus is a successful predator, you may see a different pattern.
So in terms of thinking about these ecological dynamics between
viruses and bacteria, what do you think can be done with
the more static metagenomic data that we have and then your thoughts on kind of
collecting maybe more longitudinal data
to examine those ecological
dynamics?
Of course. So thank you for that question.
So for the particular figure that you're alluding to,
we use the computational workflow from another group,
I think it's out of the Jackson Lab, called iPhop,
that uses a variety of computational
methods.
It's a wrapper really that
brings together a bunch of different methods to accurately predict
phage-host pairs.
It's been pretty well validated experimentally.
So we think it's the current
best available workflow.
And when we went back to our computational predictions,
we were able to demonstrate in a separate bit of work that hasn't yet
been published, is that
really strong co-occurrence and co-exclusion patterns do a
pretty darn good job of predicting phage-host pairs.
Meaning if the abundance or prevalence of a particular
virus is very tightly coupled to its predicted bacterial
host, that's usually evidence of a pretty bona fide
relationship.
All right, thanks. I also had a question about the
EBV, because I think
you did some modeling to
show that maybe if we have only X amount of sequencing depth, you're not going to
be able to capture a lot of the EBV.
And you see this discordance with the seropositivity and the detection.
I'm wondering your thoughts on how much of that is due to lack of sequencing depth
versus
an infection that's just been cleared and/or has a
sink-
Yeah
... in some other organ sites other than the blood that may be driving
that.
Yeah.
I guess I'll say what I think, but there's limited evidence that
supports this, but I think it is predominantly sequencing depth.
I think the concept of actually fully clearing an infection is actually probably
rare. I think there will almost always be one copy in the
course of the trillions of cells that we have in our body at a minimum.
And so, yeah, downsampling and the things that one could do with
our data supported that intuition.
Certainly other reservoirs, the
epithelia in the esophagus, for example, is also a
reservoir as well as B cells. So all of that modeling was just strictly B cell
associated.
But yeah, exactly the way that I think about this is just at a 30X whole
genomeYou're only going to get that right tail of the distribution.
But I think irrespective of depth, this is a distinct sort of population.
That distribution is reflected in what
we're ultimately measuring. So I think if we had, say,
1,000-fold deeper sequencing on everyone, we would then have that full
distribution. You could do quantitative analyses, but I would think you would find
a lot of the same things that we're seeing. That's at least how I think about it.
That makes sense.
Thanks so much for the session. This was really great.
I had a question about candida stuff.
So I was really intrigued by all those different strains with their different
properties in terms of forming hyphae.
I was just hoping you could say a little bit more about that.
Do you see any associations with candidalysin excretion?
Do you see different colonization?
Maybe have you tested any of them in the mouse model to see if they're able to
infiltrate tumors differentially, stuff like that.
Yeah. So we are exploring that. We also were struck by the
diversity because
when you think of species, they are actually strains, and the strains
are the way the human population works.
And we are looking into that. So we developed those
association studies, and we have a CRISPR platform.
So we are basically walking across the genome to look actually
for colonization
factors. Candidalysin was recently shown
to be a factor that is required for colonization,
at least in the mouse gut.
How that works in human system and all that
is not known. But yeah, so it's a very
interesting area because if you can define patients that carry
strains that are actually colonizing
better, that will be very important when we actually do the
clinical studies as well.
Thank you.
Hi. Oops. I'm Meredith Heller from Fred Hutch.
And
had a couple of questions about the fungal
microbiome. One, do you think that the
fungi are actually contributing metabolically to the etiology
of the tumors? And also, I
thought that you said that you expected the pattern of
fungal colonization to be the same across different tumor
types, and I'm curious what the underlying
hypothesis is.
Yeah. So not that the pattern is probably similar
across the tumor types, but across the tumor types, you can find
actually candida colonization in--
We think it's in the mucosa. That's what we are actually trying to
investigate also in other tumor types.
And it's able to do that because
it can survive in
a oxygenic environment, but then also it can
survive in the gut.
And that's very particular kind of properties that
candida has. Metabolically, if it can
affect the tumor progression through the
production of metabolites, it's something that we are investigating.
But for all those studies where we are doing the pangenome
studies,
we have those organoid cultures where we are testing that.
We still don't have any major hits
for metabolic pathways, really. But
we have some ideas about
ability basically to adhere
and then
influence the growth. So that's where we are moving those things towards
now.
So since they're mucosally-oriented, are
they capable of degrading mucins?
Is that an extracellular enzyme they excrete from that?
So
Candida albicans is very interesting because it can grow on a lot of
substrates and it can
use some of the mucins, but
we didn't try something super purified.
We basically work with the
mucus collection, and it can use it as source if you actually
limit the media. And this is what we are thinking, actually, how they
colonize more into the tumor, because that's some
other data that I didn't show. They somehow have this
tropic ability to go into the tumor region more than
in the non-associated tissues. So
they probably would not go just for the tumor, but there
is something that they feed on. So that's what we are trying to understand,
what they are really attracted to.
Thank you.
So it appears we're going to wrap up just a little bit early.
I'd like to conclude by thanking my esteemed co-speakers, and
thanks to all of you for your engagement and your
attention. Thank you.